[Musique]
étant un grand fan de twilight princess
je me devais de faire cette vidéo car
une question troubles mon enfance qui
hélas thuan esprit de la lumière en
forme de chèvre veillant sur le village
de tôle il est un réel mystère dans
l'univers de zelda
tout d'abord il faut savoir que la toile
est l'un des quatre esprit de la lumière
chargé autrefois par les déesses de
préserver la lumière sur le monde
d'hyrule
à l'instar des autres et ce prix-là
thuan veille donc sur la région portant
son nom comprenant le village de tôle et
les forêts aux alentours son apparence
peut par ailleurs être assimilés aux
chèvres de tôle tall est un petit
village situé à l'extrême sud d'hyrule
d'ailleurs ce village est un petit peu
coupé de cette région il n'existait pas
durant la période de kind of time
antécédents de twilight princess dans la
timeline officiel certains suspects ray
que ce village serait le village kokiri
d'ocarina of time
justement c'est vrai pourquoi pas mais
je n'en suis pas si sûr même si ce
village est très reculés et les cookies
rit sont absentes de twilight princess
le seul rapport avec ces derniers le
temple sylvestre dans les portes possède
le signe kokiri mais cette dernière
reste tout à fait possible je reste
indécis pour moi les habitants de tôle
se sont réfugiées justement à l'écart
suite à la grande guerre entre les
îliens et léguer rudeau commandé par cas
d'un corps on peut même aller plus loin
rappelez-vous ligne de majora's mask a
disparu on ne sait pas du tout ce qu'il
est devenu après son histoire à termina
il serait allé à tall pour y mener des
jours paisibles
ce serait pourquoi plus personne ne l'a
jamais revu tous les coupés d'hyrule par
la forêt et avec le temps aurait donné
naissance au link de twilight princess
un simple berger qui a toujours vécu at
all vous trouvez ça tiré par les cheveux
vous souvenez du loup doré qui apprend
les techniques ancestrales du héros aux
liens que de tp et bien ce loup apelle
link monfils et c'est justement le link
d'ocarina of time donc celui de majora's
mask qui transmet son savoir à link de
dpc confirmé dans les rues l'historial
que c'est le link de karine
time donc c'est quand même un peu gros
vous ne trouvez pas pour en revenir à la
toile qui pourrait bientôt l'être il
faut savoir que seuls les trois autres
esprits de la lumière selon les dires de
l'anel serait intervenu dans le
bannissement des twill y les traîtres
lorsque ces derniers cherchaient à
utiliser les cristaux douvres
d'après ses dires je pencherais pour la
vie que la toinette apparu après les
trois autres esprits dans le temps qu'il
soit arrivé justement après le
bannissement dit willy je ne parlerai
pas de la théorie de la tetra force car
je ne trouve pas qu'elle correspond à la
toile car la quatrième partie est comme
qui dirait sombre ce qui est tout le
contraire de la toile de plus cette
théorie est très complexe d'ailleurs
elle a été démentie par nintendo
je tourne autour du pot depuis le début
car je n'ai tout simplement pas de
réponse pour ne rien vous cacher la
toinette un esprit de la lumière il est
ici pour prospérer la lumière sur la
région d'hyrule la seule théorie que je
peux émettre et que tall est un village
apparues après le temps d'ocarina of
time ce village fut créée par désignant
un réfugié de la guerre entre îliens et
guérido ils sont coupés d'hyrule jane le
précise même c'est une région annexe les
ds ne laissant tomber aucun il ya aurait
donc envoyé un nouvel esprit de la
lumière pour protéger le village de tôle
village qui abrite d'ailleurs le nouvel
élu qui sauvera le monde du crépuscule
et de la lumière de ganon 2
les déesses devait le savoir et ont tout
fait pour veiller sur link cet esprit
serait apparu plus tard après le
bannissement des truies lit par les
autres esprits ce petit village est
quand même bien mystérieux et nous fait
réellement réfléchir sur l'histoire de
la saga zelda mais c'est ce qui me fait
rêver
j'espère cette vidéo vous aura plu
n'hésitez pas à venir ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires cette vidéo
est purement subjective merci à ceux qui
laisseront un pouce bleus équipes
partageant la vidéo c'était ago rock que
le lay honneur soit avec
[Musique]